I feel like I'm a little kid but I'm not
I'm gonna dolt woman I can do this my
name is Emily I'm new to BuzzFeed and I
really want to make some new friends so
to do that I've decided to challenge
myself to sit with strangers every day
during lunch this week I'm equal parts
excited and a bit terrified it may seem
easy to some people but for me
personally talking to new people is
really difficult even though I knew
people were probably going to be nice to
me I was still a sweaty mess it's gonna
be fine it's gonna be really good I'm
gonna ask these cute boys don't worry
mum one second
do you mind if I join you is that okay
awesome
what's your name promise is that I have
difficulty making new friends of it yes
the problem isn't in you pop it might be
with like my first impression like right
now I'm sweating right now I'm like
scared sure like very pretty and very
good eye contact and like I already
messed up because I like forgot that I'm
I'm sorry
thank you for taking the time to talk to
me thank you so I'm pretty well
I see two people but they're like in
conversation I don't interrupt so just
like hang back for a second and I'm
gonna go approach okay bye
I'm filming a video where I hang out and
they can take me with people I don't
know 30 lunch time okay can I hang out a
little bit
I'm Emily all right so nice to meet you
what do you guys do a BuzzFeed a podcast
oh sorry I've only heard your voice I
would see your baby to like working it
BuzzFeed like yeah everyone's really
diverse and cool and like part of the
reason for doing this videos like
selfishly I want to talk to everyone and
this like gives me an excuse to be like
hey can I borrow your surely personal
conversation and just be like hi I'm
Emily you guys wanna fight you want your
tea today
[Music]
[Music]
is it alright if I join you
oh my gosh so what are your opinions on
The Bachelor once we got the ball
rolling small talk turned into regular
conversation I started to relax more I
talked about everything with everyone
from buying homes to our favorite
podcasts
or even how your pet sexuality is a bit
creepy so they come away and I said you
don't know what this is
because I've wanted to talk to you thank
you yeah I was like too nervous it's
like it's really hard to eat in front of
people you don't know things I found out
this week I finally ate in front of the
Pope so I'm excited about that I still
have a lot of Sandwich left but um you
know I'll go find a corner I felt really
proud of myself for doing this
I was nervous every time I approached a
new table but I still did it the
connections I made doing this for
genuine afterwards people came up to me
and still wanted to talk even though
there's no camera around to film it
overall this was a great experience I
had awkward moments funny moments even
some failure moments I recommend this
experience I want you guys to try it out
to get out of your bubble tell me how it
goes in the comments below
oh that went really well I am stressed
sweating pretty bad
[Music]